Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight,
Alex Rodriguez joins the Tank.
Rodriguez:
Here's the problem
with a lot
of young entrepreneurs.
As it gets bigger
and bigger and bigger,
it gets
a lot more challenging.
This baseball legend
is also a business heavy‐hitter
with over 20 years of experience
in entrepreneurship
and investing.
What is your
competitive advantage?
Why do I want to invest
in your business?
Like, we don't let any excuse
get in our way.
'Cause I'm scared right now,
but I'm fighting it
to be here in front of you all.
What do you have in sales
this year?
$100,000.
Ouch!
At some point,
you got to have sales.
You need sizzle.
A deal with me
will not stink.
I think
you're a perfectionist.
Perfection is the enemy
of profitability.
I'll give you
the $500,000.
Wow. Shark.
O'Leary: Ooh!
Whose house is it?
Mark's house.
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is a high‐tech solution
to yucky pee pads for your pet.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Alan Cook.
I'm from Chicago.
Yay!
And my business
is Brilliant Pad.
I'm seeking $500,000
in exchange for a 5%
equity stake in our company.
The pet industry is huge,
yet it's little dogs
under 25 pounds
that are the biggest
and fastest‐growing segment
of the dog population.
And, Sharks, do you know what
every small dog has in common?
Poo‐poo.
Pee‐pee.
They do.
Small dogs have small bladders
and soil billions of potty pads
every year.
And if you've ever handled
a soiled pad,
you know they are disgusting.
We may love our little friends,
but we hate
the mess they leave behind.
And that's why
we created Brilliant Pad.
Brilliant Pad
automatically replaces
a dirty pad
with a clean, fresh one,
so you never have to handle
a stinky, soiled pad ever again.
Mm.
As you can see,
Brilliant Pad handles
number one and number two.
Then it wraps
and seals the waste
so your home is clean
and odor‐free.
Each roll is equivalent
to 27 pads.
So you can leave this alone
for days, even weeks at a time.
Then when the roll is used up,
simply remove and replace.
And the best part is, your hands
stay clean the entire time.
Sharks, with your investment
and your help,
we can grow sales big and fast.
So, who's gonna join me and make
dirty pads a thing of the past?
That's interesting.
Can ‐‐ Can we see
that working?
Yeah.
So, the machine will
advance the pad automatically
according to
an adjustable timer,
which you can set to advance
one, two, or three times a day.
Or you can advance the pad any
time at the touch of a button.
We can see how the machine
takes in the solids,
and it'll wrap up the liquids,
and everything dirty
is sealed inside
while the outside
stays clean and dry.
Turd tube that's sitting
with the first turd a month ago.
Yeah.
Wouldn't that
have an odor?
You would
expect it to smell.
I certainly would.
I thought you might want
to see one.
[ Chuckling ]
Oh, gosh.
A used turd tube.
So, this was loaded up
several weeks ago,
before I left Chicago.
Really?
There are 27 helpings
of leftovers in this roll.
Please,
bring the turd tube to me.
All right,
we got to see this.
You would ‐‐ You would
expect the leftovers
to be horribly stinky
after just a couple of days.
Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
Greiner:
How does it smell?
[ Laughter ]
Bordeaux. 1982.
You know, um,
this is pretty good.
My gosh.
[ Laughs ]
Alan, can you give me a little
bit of your background?
Cook: Certainly.
I, uh, made my way
into the pet industry
by accident over 15 years ago.
It was the fault
of a former girlfriend,
uh, because she came with cats
who used a litter box.
And I cleaned
a stinky litter box,
and I thought it was disgusting.
And I thought to myself,
"We can put people on the moon.
I wish this thing
would clean itself."
So I ended up creating
the scoop‐free, automatic,
self‐cleaning litter box.
We turned an idea ‐‐
That was yours?
Yes.
Wow.
That gives you total street cred
on this deal.
You've done it before.
Exactly.
What do you have
in sales this year?
We just started production.
We ran an Indiegogo campaign
earlier in the spring.
We sold approximately $100,000
in 30 days at ‐‐
The average price point was ‐‐
was $125.
When do you expect
to deliver and fulfill?
So, we are in production.
I ‐‐ We expect shipments
to be in customers' hands
in six weeks.
What's your cost?
So,
our cost of goods ‐‐
Um, the machine is $54.
Okay.
Retail price is $149.
And then
for making it in bulk ‐‐
So it's $149 for the unit.
How much for the rolls?
Uh, the rolls, on subscription,
as little as $19.99, delivered.
When I went
to business school,
my summer job
was at the Bisto brands
to launch the first
10‐times‐more‐absorbent
kitty litter.
Mm.
Did it ever
come on the market?
It was
a premium product.
Yep.
I thought
it would never work.
And I learned
something extraordinary ‐‐
people love their pets.
Yes.
And they want their experiences,
in terms of excrement,
to be pleasant
for their animals.
Mm‐hmm.
And listen, the people
paid a fortune for it.
It was
a huge success.
Yeah.
It was my first
big marketing gig.
And what year
did you do that?
[ Laughter ]
But my point is, I have
experience in this market...
He has experience
in every single thing.
...and I believe
that people
really take care
of their pets...
So, he ceases
to amaze me.
...so I'm gonna make you
an offer, okay?
You want me to pay
$10 million valuation,
basically, right?
Yes. Yes.
Not loving it.
Not feelin' the love
at that valuation.
I hear ya.
But I'll give you
the $500,000 as debt.
Okay.
Okay?
Cuban:
Of course you will.
And I'll take
10% equity.
And...
you know, I'll squat on it
and promote it.
[ Laughter ]
This is Kevin's version
of the Squatty Potty.
And there will go
all of your sales!
Cook: What would be
the repayment terms on that?
Alan, what is
the interest rate?
Interest at 11%.
Wow. Shark.
Corcoran: I don't even know
if your ask is reasonable,
quite honestly,
because it's kind of like
we have to have
a tremendous amount of faith
that you're gonna deliver
the kinds of sales
you're dreaming about.
Mm‐hmm.
For me, it's a little too
high‐risk, so I'm out.
Mm‐hmm.
Yeah.
Rodriguez: Yeah,
so Alan, first of all,
very impressive pedigree.
And I think you have something
very impressive here.
For me,
I don't see my brand
really moving the
dog‐poop market, for example.
Cuban: I don't know
I don't know.
But I wish you
a lot of luck.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
I don't know,
Alex.
[ Laughter ]
I have the only
viable offer out,
and two Sharks
have just dropped out.
And what's happening here
is you're losing leverage.
Every time
another Shark drops out...
Kevin, let ‐‐
let me help you with that.
...I can't help
the greed come back.
Alan, Kevin and I look
at valuations differently.
Yep.
I look at valuations
as an opportunity,
but I also have to look at it
on return, right?
Sure.
In order to make back $500,000
with only 5% equity,
you have to generate $10 million
in after‐tax profits.
That's difficult,
right?
Mm‐hmm.
That's a big,
big hit.
While I think
it's a nice business,
I don't think
it's that big a business.
Yep.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Ooh!
Alan, I'm not
feelin' the love.
Because the risk is,
if Lori drops out ‐‐
Well, I'm not
dropping out.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Alan has an offer on the table
from Kevin
for his self‐cleaning
pee‐pad business, Brilliant Pad.
But Lori also seems interested.
The risk is,
if Lori drops out ‐‐
Well, I'm not
dropping out.
What is your offer?
♪♪
I'll give you
the $500,000.
Okay.
I would like
to get back...
$5 per unit...
on every one sold
until I hit the $500,000.
And then
I will do it for...
♪♪
...8%.
Okay.
Lori, why are we fighting
like cats and dogs?
Why don't you simply join
my deal for $2.50?
We ask him for 10%.
We do straight debt.
And he pays us the interest
and the principle back,
and he's got
two Sharks.
It's a great deal.
It would be a better deal
with 5%.
But I'm not sure I want to do
a deal with anybody.
♪♪
So...
So these are ‐‐
So, now you've really got
a tough decision,
because basically,
one is a royalty‐based loan...
Yep.
...and the other
is a straight‐debt deal
you pay back
in a traditional manner.
I'm changing my offer.
♪♪
So, I'm gonna give you
the $500,000,
and I'd like $5 a unit
on every one sold.
And I will help you
blow this up on QVC,
maybe infomercial.
You know,
that's what I do,
and I can really
blow things up fast.
My Simply Fit Board ‐‐
we did $150 million in sales
in less than a year.
Mm‐hmm.
So, $500,000.
$5 back per unit
until I get back my $500,000.
And then, 5%.
♪♪
Wow.
Mm.
I just lowered mine.
Ah‐ha.
That's interesting.
And Bad Bath & Beyond
is my very strong partner,
as is Walmart
and every other store.
You want to get into
Bed Bath & Beyond,
you want Walmart, you want
Target. We've all done that.
We've been around
for nine years.
It's not the same.
It's all about
demonstration.
What I'm trying to do
is manage my cash through
the early part of launch.
That's ‐‐ That's the piece
I'm sensitive to.
Mm‐hmm.
So I would want to either
lower the royalty
and spread it out
over a longer period of time
or kind of defer it.
So I would have an interest
in keeping it at the $500,000
at $2.50 per unit
until you're paid back.
Uh, but then I think
the thing I need beyond that is,
when we start selling
in other channels,
we're gonna have a need
that goes well beyond $500,000.
So if you can follow it up
with a facility
for $1 million or more...
I don't have the problem
in funding,
so if you get
the purchase orders...
Mm‐hmm.
...I'm happy to help finance
the purchase orders
because that means
we have a firm sale.
Yep.
I don't have
any risk there.
Mm‐hmm.
So, I will take
that offer.
Okay.
But you need to show me
you're decisive.
Kevin, you're wonderful,
but she's from Chicago,
so I have to go with ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
Corcoran: Hallelujah!
Hallelujah. [ Chuckles ]
Thank you.
Congrats.
Very smart.
[ Chuckles ]
Very smart product.
Appreciate it.
Cuban:
Congratulations, Alan.
Thank you. Thank you.
Rodriguez: Good luck,
Alan. Congrats.
You can take
the turd roll with you.
[ Laughing ]
Please do!
Thanks, guys.
I picked Lori over Kevin because
she relates to our customers.
With this deal with Lori,
every pet's business
is gonna be our business.
You should've rolled into
my deal.
Why?
Because it was
a better structure.
You were higher up
on the balance sheet.
You took less risk,
and you would've made
more money.
You don't have
the financial creativity.
Learn from me,
grasshopper.
Listen to
what I'm doing.
I don't want
to learn from something
that hangs upside down
when they sleep.
No, no, no.
Lori, all men are brilliant.
You know that.
That's right,
all men are brilliant.
It's not a man thing.
It's just
good financial structure.
Learn from it.
I'm gonna invoice you.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator: In season 8,
Bruno, Brandon, and Steven
made a deal with Robert Herjavec
for their beach towels
with a cause, Sand Cloud.
Millennials need
a social cause to get behind
in order
to support you.
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
♪♪
Our first year in business,
we did only $30,000 in sales.
It's only been four months
since airing on "Shark Tank,"
and we've done $2.7 million.
Our mission
is to save marine life.
We donate 10% of our profits
back to our charity partners.
Today, we're in Hawaii with
one of our marine‐life partners,
the Hawaii Wildlife Fund,
and we're here to clean up
Ka'ehu Beach.
Thank you so much, everybody,
for helping out today.
Herjavec:
I invested in Sand Cloud
because they're
great entrepreneurs,
and secondly, it's the message.
They want to give back
to the ocean,
and they want
to save the fishes.
♪♪
Brandon: Eight million
tons of plastic
are dumped into our oceans
every year.
This beach
is a catcher's mitt
for the North Pacific
Convergence Zone.
It makes it one of
the most polluted beaches
in all of Hawaii.
Steven: Look at all of this.
This is insane.
Herjavec: Man, I can't believe
what I'm seeing here today.
Such a beautiful location,
but there's rope,
there's tires, there's plastic.
There's tons of garbage
on this beach.
We're getting to a point
that there'll be more plastic
in the ocean
than there will be fish.
And that's sad.
It's sad for future generations.
But it's also great
that we can help in a small way.
We got over
1,600 pounds of trash!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Herjavec: Love my investment
in Bruno, Steve, and Brandon.
I think not only are we gonna
make a lot of money,
we're gonna save
a lot of fishes.
Steven:
We're just three friends
that came up with an idea
on the beach,
and now we have
a thriving business
and we're changing the world
one towel at a time.
Save the fishies!
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a way
to always have money on hand
for tipping.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
We are
Hector and Maria.
We live
in Phoenix, Arizona,
both born and raised
in Puerto Rico.
We are seeking $150,000 for
5% equity in our company, Bravo,
transforming the way
people get paid
for a job well‐done.
Sharks, have you ever wanted
to tip or pay
your valet attendant,
bartender, or musician,
but then you realize
you didn't have any cash?
Think about
how many times
you have been
in a similar situation,
wanting to tip or pay
but out of cash.
In the age of plastic
and mobile pay,
millions of Americans
who depend on cash tips
to make a living
are losing out
more and more.
But Bravo is
a seamless payment solution
that allows you to find
and pay...anyone!
Unlike other mobile‐payment
solutions in the market,
with Bravo,
you don't need to be friends.
And you do not exchange any
of your personal information.
Imagine that Monte Pittman
is a street performer
and that he depends on those
cash tips to make a living,
to feed his family.
[ Guitar playing ]
Corcoran: Wow.
Cuban: Yeah!
Rodriguez: Wow.
Greiner: Beautiful.
Very nice.
Maria: Okay, after such
a brilliant performance,
I want to tip Monte,
but I don't have cash
on me.
However,
I always have my phone.
So this is where
Bravo comes in handy,
because now you can find him
by proximity on the app.
You search him
by name
if you don't have him
by proximity.
Enter the amount
you want to tip.
And at the end
of the transaction,
you can enter a rating
or a comment.
It's that simple
to tip or pay
and to empower a hard‐working
person like Monte.
He has been so generous
to perform for us,
but he is actually
a renowned musician,
a singer/songwriter,
largely known for being
Madonna's guitarist for years,
and now
a Bravo fan.
Whoo!
Thank you, Monte.
Bravo to you,
Monte.
Thank you.
Sharks, we're open
for questions.
Corcoran: Help me with something
I just don't understand.
How do you get the money
into his pocket?
I feel like I missed
something basic there.
I find him by proximity
on my app ‐‐
Greiner: But does he
have to have the app?
Yeah, but how does he
get the cash?
He does
have to have the app.
He has to have a phone.
It's free
to download.
Okay.
It takes seconds
to download.
So, how do I know that he has
Bravo when he's on the street,
or I want to tip him
anywhere I find him?
We support them
with a point‐of‐sale material
that lets people know
that they're accepting Bravo.
Right now,
we penetrated 25%
of the service industry
in Arizona ‐‐
valet attendants, musicians,
service professionals.
We already
dominated Arizona,
and we're already seeing
more than 1,000 cities ‐‐
What does
"dominating Arizona" mean?
How many dollars in tips
are you processing a month?
Almost $1 million.
A month?
Well, in the lifetime
of the app.
In the lifetime
of the application.
But the way
we're scaling this ‐‐
We go to the service
professionals, to the artists,
and then
they help us grow
because they talk to their
fan base and their customers.
Cuban: But what about like,
Venmo, right?
Why don't you just put a sign
that has your PayPal address,
has your Venmo address,
has Facebook Messenger payment,
and just
let anybody pick?
Because it's not
a secure instrument
to connect people
that are strangers.
Is there anyone else
doing this?
Bravo is
a unique product.
How do you make money
off of this model?
We charge
a 2% convenience fee.
So you take
2% of the tip.
No, we ‐‐
No.
From the tipper?
The person that pays ‐‐
For example, if I'm gonna
tip $10, I pay $10.20.
The person receiving receives
a whole $10 in the bank account.
Rodriguez: Can I hear a little
bit about your background?
Well, I come from a small town
called Isabela, Puerto Rico.
It's beautiful.
And I grew up in a family ‐‐
extremely poor.
My mother made
a dollar an hour.
We were six
at home.
But I'm so proud of that
because she told us,
"I qualify for support
from the government,
but I don't take it
because I want my children
to earn the money they make."
And that got instituted
in my heart,
and I have earned everything
I have in life.
I graduated high school
at age 16
with a grade‐point average
of 4.0.
That's great.
I went
to the University of Puerto Rico
and obtained
a bachelor's degree
and then
a master's degree
from the University of Texas
at Austin.
Good for you.
And after that,
I started my career in Nabisco,
marketing
and business development,
and understanding
that you always
have to talk
to your customers.
After that, Bravo,
which is the pride of my life.
Because my mother used to
depend on those tips,
I know
how much it hurts at home
when there's a week
of poor tipping.
Maria, can I ask you how you got
to a $3 million valuation?
Yes.
You want
to hear about me?
[ Laughter ]
I would love to, yes.
I'm sorry, Hector,
go ahead.
I'm married to her,
the CEO.
I am
a medical doctor
and a board‐certified
gastroenterologist
and liver‐transplant
specialist.
Did you leave your job
in the medical profession
and are doing this
full‐time?
Hector is working
as a physician,
and he's also the COO for Bravo
and my co‐founder.
I am 100% dedicated
to Bravo.
And I haven't, uh,
finished the answer
about how
we make money.
Bravo has data aggregation
based on user behavior.
That ‐‐ It's predicted
by the machine learning.
We have
a well‐thought strategic plan,
and it has
three pillars.
Can I just leave your
three pillars for a minute?
Because when you start
talking like that,
I‐I feel
I get more confused. [ Laughs ]
You said you want to make it
easy to tip or pay.
The more
I sit here and listen,
the less easy
it feels to me.
That's my read on it.
I could imagine you spending
endless millions of dollars
building this until you get
the mass that you really want.
I fear how much money this thing
is gonna take.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
Cuban: As a business,
this is very tough.
Doing $1 million in gross value
sounds amazing,
but it's only $20,000
in revenue to you.
If you get to $100 million,
then it's still only $2 million
revenue to you.
That's the supreme challenge.
How do you overcome that?
We have two routes
of monetization.
One comes from
the transactional fee,
and the other one comes
from the machine learning.
We have data aggregation
based on user behavior.
You could use it
at a restaurant,
you could use it as a musician
or valet attendant,
essentially to reach out
to your customers,
see their behavior,
the comments they get,
insights into
what's happening,
where people are.
Predicting who's more likely
to come back.
Yeah,
but that's what Yelp does.
Send deals.
But this is really private
for you, me, the merchant,
the vendor, to get that data
back and understand how ‐‐
Okay, now get that to me
to a revenue.
Okay,
everybody likes data.
When we did the test
in the quarter one,
we were able
to charge
because of the value
to the small merchant.
So, Lori walks by the restaurant
'cause you know they have Bravo,
and you say, "Hey, Lori,
come into our restaurant."
And that restaurant
pays you how and how much?
The subscription model
is $5 premium per month.
And with only 65 customers
that we tested it with,
we produced about $15,000
in income for the app,
so that is really
where the money is at.
And you were able
to find ‐‐
if it was just
a one‐month test ‐‐
you were able to find
3,000 restaurants?
And that's
how you made $15,000?
Yes,
we had ‐‐
In the first quarter.
Well,
that's impressive.
Yeah.
O'Leary:
That's impressive.
My problem with this deal
is it's the Wild West
in payment processing.
And I think it's gonna require
a lot more money
to figure out
what works and what doesn't.
♪♪
I'm out.
It's a real pity because
I love you personally.
I love it when you
suck up to me. It really helps.
I got to tell you.
[ Chuckles ]
So, first of all,
incredible story.
I mean,
where you come from.
You really are
the American Dream.
For me,
I'm back‐of‐envelope guy.
I want to keep it really simple.
If we can't go to dinner
and in the first few minutes,
on the back
of an envelope,
really explain to me
what the business model is,
i‐it's confusing.
It's just
too many moving parts.
Uh, I wish you luck,
but for that reason, I'm out.
But we appreciate your
kind words and your example,
what you have done
for the Hispanic community.
And hopefully
when we make it with Bravo,
we're gonna also be
an agent of change
and produce more opportunities
for minorities.
Thank you
for what you have done.
Maria, you are one of
the most impressive people
I've ever seen
on the carpet here.
I'm your customer completely,
and I've talked with Mark.
We would like
to invest in it together.
Corcoran: Wow.
Oh, my God,
that's a dream come true.
Don't get happy yet.
Here's the offer.
All right.
$150,000 for 15%.
But you get
both of us.
Um...I ‐‐
Ouch.
Whoa.
I think 15% is ‐‐ is quite high
for the $150,000,
and I know
that you bring a lot of value.
So we're gonna counter.
We will do $150,000
for 10%,
but we will give
each one of you
1% in advisory fees
for a total of 12%.
♪♪
Greiner: Well,
what do you think?
♪♪
[ Whispering indistinctly ]
If you make it
2% advisory shares each,
then I think
we can do it.
♪♪
[ Whispering indistinctly ]
That's a deal.
Great!
[ Applause ]
I love you.
Congratulations.
Oh,
it's gonna amazing.
Maria: Gracias.
Bye‐bye.
Don't forget
to tip me.
[ Laughter ]
Hector: Having two Sharks
on the Bravo team is...
Both:
A dream come true.
I‐I still need
a pinch.
Can you pinch me?
Are you awake?
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the tank
is an easier way
to find a pickup game.
♪♪
How you doing, Sharks?
My name is Donte Morris.
And I'm Dominic Morris.
We're twin brothers
out of Oakland, California.
Our company
is called HoopMaps.
We're seeking $100,000
in exchange for 5% equity
in our company.
Now, Sharks, how many
of you guys like to stay active?
I like
to stay active.
One of the things
I like to do to stay active
is play basketball ‐‐
pickup basketball ‐‐
but I always find it
difficult to do.
Bro, what you mean?
You know you can text me.
Man, you know you don't never
pick up your phone.
How about you hop in your car
and drive to a different park?
I do, but every time I drive
to a different park,
I'm either
just missing the good game
or I'm spending my time
waiting an hour
just to hop into
another game.
It's the 21st century.
There has to be
a better way.
Well, there is
It's called HoopMaps.
HoopMaps is a mobile app
that allows users
to find pick‐up games
wherever you're at.
Ah.
And it's very easy
to use.
All you do
is log in to the app,
you create a username
and a password,
and voilà,
you're in.
Once you're in,
it's gonna send you
to a map screen
that'll have two icons.
Blue icon represents
games that haven't started yet,
while the orange icon
represents games
that's already
in progress.
And it's very easy
to create a game, as well.
Just hit the app screen
in the top right corner.
Once you create the app screen,
you just put in the place,
the time of the game,
the game duration.
You can even invite people
to the game, too.
So, I can invite Alex,
I can invite Mark.
[ Chuckles ]
And I just
hit "create,"
and then you're right there
in the game.
Wait, hold up,
you didn't add me, though.
My bad.
[ Chuckles ]
The beauty about HoopMaps,
though,
it sends all users
a push notification
within
a 25‐mile radius.
So, I see you guys playing,
so I'm gonna add myself in.
Mark, Alex,
you guys want to come down,
get a quick game of two,
see what you guys got?
I'm gonna pick Alex.
I'm a life‐long
Yankees fan, so...
Wrong sport.
I wish
we had a bat.
Donte: I know
you play ball. Let's go.
You're twins,
so which one's mine?
Cuban:
Yeah, I know.
[ Laughter]
[ Chatter ]
Checking up.
Checking ‐‐ me and you?
Me and you.
Okay.
Let's do it, let's do it.
Let's go.
♪♪
Oh!
Oh, shot!
Ooh, nice!
Corcoran:
Whoa! Yeah, baby!
You can tell
who owns the basketball team.
Greiner:
[ Chuckles ] Yeah.
Oh, shot!
Game!
Ohh!
Corcoran:
Oh, again ‐‐ two.
All right.
Whose house is it?
Mark's house.
[ Chuckles ]
Yeah, yeah.
O'Leary: Guys,
what are your sales?
How do you make money?
Donte: So, our revenue model
right now is,
having a premium subscription
through our models,
we have 50,000 users.
So you have 50,000
using it now
but nobody's
a premium payer yet, right?
Correct.
When are you gonna flip
that switch to premium?
That's actually
why we're here now.
Uh, we actually just
really released our app,
you know,
just only in January.
Now, 50,000 users sounds good,
right,
but you got to be
in the same city,
otherwise,
it doesn't really work.
Right.
So where are most
of your users at?
Most of our users right now
is in New York City,
but, uh, the way
we launched this,
75% of our users,
through Google search.
So, people are typing in
"pickup basketball."
We lead this space.
And so have you had
50,000 downloads?
How many people are using it
on a daily basis?
So, we have 10,000
daily active users.
That's not bad, guys.
That's actually not bad at all.
Who did the coding
for this?
Who created your app?
Yes, same question.
So actually,
when we thought of this app,
we said, "One of us is gonna
have to know how to code,"
so I took three months out of
the year, learned how to code,
and I built the basic framework
of this app.
That is awesome.
Man...that's badass.
Thank you.
Dominic: We're the type
of people that, you know,
see something
and then, like,
we don't let any excuse
get in our way.
Can I ask you how you got into
a $2 million valuation?
We're the leader
in this space.
We have 72%
of our natural search
come through people
looking for our app online.
$2 million
is a modest valuation.
Even though
you have no revenue?
Modest?
Yeah,
I wouldn't call it modest.
I wouldn't say
it's modest.
Okay.
Cuban: Yeah, that's like
Oakland b‐ball players.
They ain't modest, right?
Can I ask you ‐‐ is this your
first business you've launched?
For the past 10 years,
we've been running
a recreational baseball league
out of Sacramento.
So, for us
to do this pickup app,
it's right up
our ally.
But what is
your competitive advantage?
Why do I want to invest
in your business?
It's because we know this age
demographic of 18 to 25.
We know
how they play.
We know what time they play.
We know their habits.
We know
their spending habits.
Look, I buy your story.
You've got 10,00 active users.
The question mark that's hanging
over you head is,
what's the conversion rate
gonna be to the premium service?
Because right now,
you make no money.
Well,
look at it this way ‐‐
What are you charging
for the premium service?
What's your
intention there?
We're gonna charge $8.99
per month or $100 per year.
What do I get
for the premium service?
So, premium users, for people
that play basketball often,
a lot of people they might want
to find more games.
We'll provide
a better experience
for our users that use the app
more frequently.
But better in what way?
Meaning like, you can see
different games in the area.
But can't you do that
on your regular app right now?
That's gonna be tough,
guys.
That's ‐‐ That's gonna be tough,
right?
'Cause when you
need guys to play,
you're not gonna say,
"All right,
you're a premium member,
come play."
You want bodies,
you know?
You don't even care
if they can play sometimes.
I've been pitched pickup
location apps a lot,
you know,
so there are other apps,
and there's websites
where you can ‐‐
you can go look
for games.
Well, a lot of apps that's out
there out the market right now,
they try to go into different
verticals with different sports.
They have 15 ‐‐
Because it didn't work
just with basketball.
Corcoran: Let's say your
premium service doesn't work.
How are you gonna make money
with this thing?
Through our brands.
Through brands. Uh, so, we ‐‐
Advertising?
Through advertising.
Yeah.
I think if you could connect
a celebrity
or some type of name to it,
that would really help you.
I'm not a super sporty girl ‐‐
I have to be honest ‐‐
so I don't think
I'm the right partner for you.
Okay.                      Okay.
I hope someone else is.
I'm sorry, I'm out.
O'Leary: What's missing
in the presentation ‐‐
it's been bothering me
since the beginning ‐‐
is you get as far as
to have an actual community
and a platform of 10,000 people
actively using it ‐‐
very cool
to get there ‐‐
but then no indication
of monetization.
This is just "maybe this works,"
"maybe this works."
That's what's missing.
I'm sorry, guys, I'm out.
♪♪
The only thing
you're really lacking
to give your brand traction
is publicity.
Yeah.
But it's very hard
to invest in a business
when you don't see a clear road
to the finish line.
Because I can't see a way
to get my money back, I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
You know, Dominic, Donte,
this is the problem ‐‐
at this point, it's just
too small of a business.
I wish you guys the best,
but I'm out.
All right, thank you.
Look, the bigger questions
is your revenue model, right?
At some point,
you got to have sales.
The subscription approach
is gonna be tough.
Trying to get 8 bucks a month
from somebody who just knows
that once they find a game,
they're just gonna go back
to that same place 90% of
the time, it's gonna be tough.
And I don't just want
to make an investment
and then have to reinvent
your business for you.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
All right, thank you.
Thank you.
‐Guys, before you leave...
‐Good luck.
...next time you pitch
an investor,
tell them
how they're going to make money.
They're too early for us.
And what I would suggest
is go out and find
the next Steph Curry,
the next Kobe Bryant
or LeBron James.
Go give that person
25% of your business.
You need sizzle.
‐That's very good advice.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Thank you.
‐Good luck, guys. Thanks.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Thank you.
Donte: We're gonna grind
like we always do.
You know,
we're from Oakland,
so we're just gonna take that
advice that we have from them
and we're just
gonna make it work.
And this time next year,
you guys will see HoopMaps
in a way bigger light.
I'm cheering for them.
And I got to tell you,
when I see diverse C. E. O. s
and founders,
it really excites me,
'cause in Silicon Valley,
there's just a huge lack.
‐Yeah.
‐Absolutely.
Right, and a huge lack
of women, as well.
Yes, absolutely.
Shocking.
Mark,
I want another rematch.
But I get the ball first
this time?
Come on. Come on.
Yes.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank is
a solution for a stinky problem.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Krista Woods.
And if you stink,
it's not my fault.
[ Laughs ]
My company's GloveStix,
and I'm looking for $150,000
for a 10% stake in my business.
As a mother
of three athletic children,
I wasted
way too much time and money
trying to get rid of the odor
that was literally living
in their sweaty gear.
I tried every chemical spray,
every wash, every "trick,"
and nothing actually worked.
That's when
I invented GloveStix.
They are an easy‐to‐use
odor‐management solution
that is solving
the world's stink problem
one athlete at a time.
My Stix are unique
because they address
the odor problem three ways.
The plastic on the outside
contains silver ions.
They will quickly inhibit 99.9%
of odor‐causing bacteria growth
in a 24‐hour period.
On the inside, you have
these replaceable inserts.
They absorb moisture
and deodorize.
They work in gloves,
shoes, boots,
cleats, helmets, kneepads.
You name it.
You just put the Stix in.
And they get the stink out.
[ Chuckles ]
So, what do you say?
A deal with me
definitely will not stink.
Are you gonna show us
your product?
Yes, absolutely.
♪♪
Thanks, Krista.
You're welcome.
Do these double
as nunchucks?
‐Thank you so much.
‐Yes, exactly.
Everybody says that.
That's why the kids love them.
♪♪
My company has two products.
What you're holding there ‐‐
Some of you
are holding GloveStix,
and shom‐‐ some of you
are holding ShoeStix.
The GloveStix
have a wrist‐guard clip
that you can hang the gloves
on a gear rack if you prefer.
Krista, you know,
I spent o‐over 20 years
in a Major League
locker room,
and, boy, I wish
I had these when I played
for some of my teammates.
Yes.
‐Yeah.
‐How does they work exactly?
So, the moisture
gets trapped inside the gear,
and then it has
nowhere to go.
It breeds
odor‐causing bacteria.
We're talking staph, E. coli,
MRSA, mold, mildew.
That's what's living
in our kids' gear.
So, let me ask you a question
about that claim.
I‐I have a lot of shoes.
They're handmade
by Italian virgins.
Yes.
They're beautiful.
‐But ‐‐ But when I ‐‐ when I...
‐Or so they say to you.
When I bring them home,
each set of shoes
has a last for them.
In other words,
they're made out of cedar.
I insert them into the shoe
to ‐‐ to hold them in place
while I don't wear that set,
and I go on
to one of my other 20 pair.
Yes.
I'm kind of a Imelda Marcos
about shoes.
Yeah, but you're the only guy
on earth that has that.
The reason they're cedar is,
true or false,
cedar absorbs odor.
It has
for hundreds of years.
It also kills bacteria.
Is this better than cedar?
It is better than cedar.
Cedar does not
actually kill bacteria.
It simply absorbs moisture.
There are no products
that do both.
That's why my products
work so well,
and that's why we're growing
at such a rapid pa‐‐ pace.
And I have a patent on it!
‐You do?
‐On bo‐‐ On both?
I just got it four days ago.
Yes!
Oh, so, how has
that panned out?
You said your sales
are skyrocketing.
Yep.
Give us the details.
So, my sales are $506,000.
‐Over what period?
A year and a half,
but $440,000 in the last year.
And where are
you selling them?
So, I sell online.
I have a website.
And I'm also on Amazon.
And then
I'm about 55% wholesale.
It's just me and the company.
I have no employees.
I also have been on QVC
four times.
I was gonna say.
I thought I recognized...
I‐I kind of stalked you
in the cafeteria one day.
[ Both laugh ]
You got through
all the bodyguards?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Totally.
$150,000 for 10%
imputes a $1.5 million value.
Yeah. So...
On ‐‐ On an odor stick.
So, what we haven't talked ‐‐‐
15 times.
[ Laughs ]
It's more than an odor stick.
But what we haven't talked about
is the re‐‐
I...
...the reoccurring income.
So, we retail these
for $29.99.
They come in the package ready
to go with the inserts in them.
So, what you're
not realizing is,
you have to change the inserts.
So what I ‐‐
What does a refill pack cost?
I retail it for $7.95.
Oh, that's expensive.
I'm never gonna agree with you
on your valuation, okay?
Rather than beat you up on it,
I'm gonna step out.
Rodriguez: What you're doing
is incredible.
Thank you.
Can you tell me a little bit
about your background?
I was 18 when I got pregnant.
I had to drop out
of high school.
Ready or not,
I was gonna be a single mother.
So I took on that challenge
despite my fears,
and I fought those fears
every single day.
And, you know,
when I was 22 years old,
I was promoted to a manager
in a male‐dominated industry.
Good for you.
And at 24 years old,
I met the most awesome guy
and married him,
and we are
still married today.
We have two other children.
And I'm not only doing it ‐‐
I am nailing it.
[ Laughs ]
Good for you.
Hear, hear!
Thank you.
For the last year and a half,
people have asked me if I was
gonna go on "Shark Tank."
I said, "No way."
And then a few months ago, I
realized it was my fear talking,
because I'm scared right now.
But I'm fighting it...
to be here in front of you all.
I know that you all can take
my product to the next level.
I know I have
something unique, original,
and I know it's going to sell.
You ‐‐ You've struck
every cord in my body.
You know,
I come from a single mother.
She had two jobs.
I would see her leaving
the house at 7:00 a. m.
and come home
at ‐‐ at midnight.
And sometimes
I would wait up at night
and count her tip money.
So I want to say
congratulations.
Thank you so much.
Krista, I want to talk
a little bit
about how you're
gonna scale this business.
Yes.
It seems to me
that you're a micromanager
and you're very connected,
which is great,
but all great entrepreneurs ‐‐
At some point, you have
to be able to delegate.
Absolutely.
That's why I'm here.
To be honest, I wouldn't be here
if I wasn't looking for someone
that has the expertise
to take me to the next level.
Krista, th‐‐ Alex
brings up a good point.
Why haven't you hired
somebody to help you?
So, I just started
hiring people
to help with sales
all over the country.
I have a few people
selling in other states.
You know what I think?
I think you're a perfectionist.
I'm not a perfectionist.
I just want to do this right.
You know, I have my kids sitting
at home watching me right now,
and I want to do this right.
Krista, look, what you've
accomplished is amazing, right?
You should be proud
of yourself.
But it's what you do next
that matters.
Yeah. Agreed.
I have a saying ‐‐
Perfection is the enemy
of profitability, right?
Perfection is also
the enemy of growth,
where you try to hold on
so tight, right?
I think you're gonna have
a hard time letting go.
I'm out.
Okay. [ Sighs ]
Krista, I have utmost respect
for you and what you've done,
but I'm a lot more interested
in you
than I am in the product.
So I personally am out.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
When I first started
my business,
I didn't take in
a whole bunch of people.
I had to wear
a lot of hats,
and I had to play
a lot of roles,
and I did it all myself.
Of course.
And I did it
because I wanted to make sure
everything was done right.
There's no one else but you
who will feel the passion,
have that dedication, and
make sure things are perfect.
And when I hear that, that
only makes me like you more.
I would like to make you
an offer.
The part about it that
I‐I don't know as much about
is the whole sports side,
with gloves and equipment
and all of that.
But I do think there's a Shark
sitting up here ‐‐ Alex ‐‐
who knows a lot
about that.
I knew that was coming, Alex.
Oh, Lori, get real.
Can bring to the table
the sports end.
You're just inviting him in
'cause he's so good‐looking.
No‐‐ [ Laugh ]
Come on.
Don't fall for this, Alex.
‐He's even cuter in person.
‐Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you.
Alex, are you interested
in this deal?
‐The sports end.
‐And she's already married,
by the way.
I think that you would be
a good partner
in us being able to hit
both sides of the market,
the GloveStix
and the ShoeStix.
Alex, I'd like
to partner with you
$150,000 for 20%
if you're interested
in going in with me.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Krista is asking for $150,000
for a 10% stake
in her odor‐eliminating product,
GloveStix.
Lori is interested, but only
if she can partner with Alex.
Alex, I'd like
to partner with you
$150,000 for 20%
if you're interested
in going in with me.
Before I answer that, Lori,
I‐I have a few concerns, Krista,
that I'd like to get into
a little bit here.
Here's the ‐‐ the problem with
a lot of young entrepreneurs.
As you scale a business,
whether it's back office
or administration
or deploying capital,
as it gets bigger
and bigger and bigger,
it gets
a lot more challenging.
I‐I'm here today
because of that reason.
I want to be ‐‐
I'm o‐‐ very open‐minded.
I'm here because I know
that I've reached
the max of my knowledge
on how to get me further.
You know what?
I‐I like you.
Lori,
I‐I would do the 20%.
As long as you're open‐minded
and let us help you
and walk you
through this process.
That's why I'm here.
You have an offer.
I do.
$150,000 from Lori and Alex
for 20%.
Yes.
What are you gonna do?
One of the things that
I talked to my husband about
was my equity.
I know I have
a huge business here,
so I was hoping
not to go over 15%.
Oh!
Is there any way
the two of you
would do the $150,000
for 15%?
I have a patent.
No one can copy me.
Are you going to take
that pushback?
What about you, Alex?
You know what?
If it's okay with Lori,
if you split it,
we have a deal.
‐17.5%.
‐So, eight‐‐
17.5%, you have a deal.
♪♪
I would do that.
Whoo!
‐Wow!
‐Yeah!
‐All right.
‐[ Screams ]
‐I'm so happy!
Come here, Mom!
Come here.
Thank you!
Oh, my God!
Yay!
All right?
You guys do not stink!
[ Laughter ]
I'm a ballplayer. I stink.
Thank you so much!
No, you don't!
You're so handsome!
So I am your first customer.
‐Congratulations, Krista.
‐Congratulations.
‐Goodbye.
‐Bye, partner.
[ Screams ]
Oh, my God!
I can't wait to tell everyone!
We're gonna have
a good time.
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my goodness.
Thank you!
[ Screams ]
Everything I've worked
for the last two years
was to be here today,
and I got a deal
with A‐Rod and Lori.
It's amazing.
It's the most incredible moment
of my life.
And it's all because
I went after my fear
and I looked it in the eye
and I tore it down.
♪♪